they say if you give a man a fish he'll
eat for a day but if you teach a man to
fish then he's got to get a fishing
license but he doesn't have any money so
he's going to get a job few comedians
are as idiosyncratic and outspoken about
their politics and their personal habits
as Doug Stanhope because you were just
worried about eating the [__] fish
and you couldn't even cook the fish
because you needed a permit for an open
flame and then the health department is
going to start asking you a lot of
questions about where are you going to
dump the scales in the guts this is not
a sanitary environment and ladies and
gentlemen if you get it if you get sick
of it all at the end of the day
not even legal to kill yourself in this
country San hope has been an
entertaining audiences with his bad
taste and unapologetically libertarian
tirades for nearly 30 years in the early
2000s he co-hosted The Man Show with Joe
Rogan including an episode where he
entered a boxing ring against disgraced
figure skater Tanya Harding this is
Tanya's first fight with a man
with Stanhope at Freedom Fest an annual
event held this year in Memphis where he
performed a characteristically
uncensored sex
is
suck [__] off the stage
if you you had a cat that left a
diarrhea Trail we talked about why he's
dreading the presidential election
season how he survived kovid's effect on
touring what he likes about psychedelics
and why he prefers creative Independence
over mainstream acceptance
[Music]
so we're at Freedom Fest which has been
held in Memphis uh what I don't but you
know what what is memphis's nickname I
don't know if it's still a murder
capital okay
um uh I don't I don't know if it has a
it's gonna happen it's something like
that though something murdery but no I
think they're both Music Nashville and
yeah Memphis yeah yeah this is the blue
well yeah I think it's uh Blues Memphis
says blues rock and roll uh rhythm and
blues maybe country western is Nashville
yeah definitely but you hate music
the Music City Miracle so it's gonna be
the Music City November Music City I
think is Now Music City miracle was Oh
wait [__] yeah that's Nashville because
that was when the Titan is through that
right yes you know lateral and Nashville
what was the team they had a team called
the Nashville Sounds that might have
been like a soccer team or something it
sounds like uh that like ABA like it's
just a chocolate thunder yeah
uh yeah Cheryl the Will Ferrell movie
what was that called Trump semi they
were the Flint they rather they were the
Fort Wayne Tropics or something like
that or something Flint uh you hate
music though
I don't like that I I'm forced to listen
to music yeah it's the only art form
that is you know 99 of the time you're
hearing it without wanting to most of
the music I know do not consent right
yeah music is rape I'll stand by that
and you have a forthcoming special that
you were going to explore this topic in
among you yeah yeah is there I mean you
are famous for being the worst person
self-promoter in history
um
I don't even know the name of this I
taped it in May and I haven't even
gotten down to like watching it all the
way through to give my editor points to
all right take this from the first show
and and use the second show that's
better
version I haven't even done that but I
don't have a title I had a title but
then I dropped the bit you know I don't
like that bit I'm not doing it so
without the bit title would make what um
what what's fueling your apathy is it is
it worse now than it was 20 years ago or
40 years ago no I and when I look back I
see I I don't see the upset that
everyone is like the fear that they're
just cranking out
I've seen everything before I'm almost
60. so uh so it go oh it's never been
this bad and you go look
oh the the genders do you remember the
70s with the uh feminism then and you we
don't want to be called Miss or uh Mrs
Miz we're going to be called Miz and
everyone's like well you you can't even
open a door for abroad anymore yeah I've
seen everything that we're going through
I've already seen it I think we if we
just said like okay everybody opens
their own doors from now on and we never
have to talk about this again but that's
that's what's happening is what was
happening in the 70s only there's more
sources of I am disappointed that
androgyny which I am older than you but
I remember androgyny was going to be
David Bowie and Twiggy uh you know so it
was going to be thin beautiful people
who kind of looked the same and instead
it's like the Campbell Soup's kids you
know where it's just chubby people who
are male and female but they look the
same in the world and they're just not
attractive yeah uh
break a nuclear war
yeah that's a new one yeah right I've
never seen that before never heard about
it inflation right so is there anything
you were I mean you famously joked about
9 11 I think minutes before it happened
leading you know many conspiracy
theorists to assume you were in on it
but you want to have the first joke
whenever a celebrity dies whatever a
natural natural or unnatural disaster
happens yeah and that was a lot easier
before social media like you have to get
to a stage and by the time you get to
the closest open mic a hundred people
have already made that joke on Twitter
so so is that fueling your apathy that
like you you can't be first so why
bother or I think well first of all that
I've had a lot of [__] happen at home
literally I had a house fire so I've
been living out of a hotel for about
nine months now uh is that bad well I
mean it's it's one thing when I lived on
the road
I spent half my you know year in hotels
anyway but that's you keep your sanity
by going to a stable home where you have
your [__] and I know where my [__] is
but if you keep moving back to a hotel
that's your home and I still have
another house in Bisbee but it's my
wife's home but I don't know where my
shirt is now I have to pack to go to
another hotel and so what how did the
fire happen just a weird electrical fire
in the Attic lost nothing but just
trying to get people to work
again yeah hey we need to talk about
unemployment right hey work on my
[__] house what uh why is it hard to
find people to work because it's a
hippie Town yeah
there's there's a lot to be said for
people who yay people you don't want to
work I could stand on a [__] a crate
waving money in my town and unless it's
like towards the end of the month before
people get their disability check
everyone knows how to do [__] they just
rather not which I don't blame them this
uh you were born in 1967 right the
Summer of Love is that why or the spring
of love right Summer Love was 67. I know
it's pretty young back then when I was
born now what I'm saying is that why you
hate hippies
I I don't hate hippies well I've here's
a problem Nick I get to a place where I
started hating everything and I just
even every commercial on TV watching the
local Morning News because it's happy
and stupid like Anchor Man and I'd smile
a little bit and the commercials which
is I hate every and I want to smash that
guy's face in and I go all right this is
me if you hate that many things it's you
but the problem is I know I have to be
right some of the time some of these
people do deserve to die and I'm letting
them all go because because I I know
that the rest of them I'm wrong about
what are what are the things that bug
you the most right now like in
contemporary America I mean one of the
things you're saying is like we're
hyping fear constantly as if it's new
and it's recycled but you know what are
what are the things that really bug the
[__] out of you of less and less of
uh [__]
I'm trying to think of
now you have nothing nothing stands
above everything else
they everything annoys me equally or
does it yeah
if I could keep the same point of view
for an entire 24-hour period I'd be
happy I would be content I'd go okay
that's how I feel about that but
sometimes you know I'm I'm punching my
laptop screen yeah and and rage over you
this is stupid what are you thinking and
then the next morning I'm like get over
it what uh what do you think about
politics these days I mean you've always
been libertarian but uh with a small L
um you know are you looking forward to
Trump Biden 2.0 or it's I I look at it
just like I look at football where yeah
when the bills were in four Super Bowls
in a row you're like all right I can't I
can't take that's what Biden Trump is
like it's not entertaining whatsoever uh
I I lost everything what once Trump got
elected I I just don't get it I don't I
don't get what how how he that could
happen yeah and not politically I'm
tapping into anger whatever but it's
still that guy it's like if Maury Povich
got elected I'd go I don't know where I
live I really don't have did you ever
say I mean you're pretty close to the
Mexican border you know why is it
celebrities whatever they're going to
leave America they always say they're
going to go to Canada they never say
I've got to go to Mexico that's what I'm
going to do in 2024. if somebody wins
I've already looked at it yeah if either
of them win I'm moving to Mexico because
it's seven miles away I'm just gonna get
an apartment over the border so it's
just gonna be me driving to the same
grocery store in America doing the same
[__] but I have an apartment is it kind
of great though that Trump won just
because it is like oh you know Trump or
Maury Povich or I don't know you know
like I try to be so positive about it
thinking that okay this could perhaps
open the door for other people uh it's
going hey if he can win I can win and
like a normal Outsider like a good
Outsider not a a wrestling villain guy
and I thought he was a billionaire as
well but no it didn't happen I thought
this next election the last one yeah
would be full of Ollie's no one nobody
like Penn jillette or someone like that
what um you know do you expect anything
out of politics no it's no president has
ever affected my life I've never if I
look back I I was born under LBJ so
again I don't really remember it but if
I I remember Carter I remember hoping
Carter would win because I always like
to pick a favorite to this day in sports
I don't follow basketball but I'll have
a favorite team an underdog and I'll
root for a yeah so uh Carter didn't do
it for you but
my life didn't change
yeah
do you think it would have changed like
if Carter had been re-elected would that
have changed the the course of human
events in a way that was measurable I
can't imagine it uh but again I have not
had a traditional life where I was
raising the kids and they're paying for
college loans I have a ninth grade
education and I I lived on people's
couches anyway it's not because it was a
tough times economically and the plant
closed it's because I was
screwing off and I'm going to move to
Vegas and I'm going to be a professional
Gambler what uh what energized you to do
that to do but like going to school at
Ninth at ninth grade and like leave home
and and wander around uh school I was uh
horrifically bored was one of the things
that killed me during the
the
corn times where people go my kids want
to go to school and they miss school for
no [__] kid wants to go to school we
would have snow days and you would [__]
in your pants sitting next to an AM
radio hoping they called your school was
closed down today that is like a great
memory the lottery yes and now you're
trying to tell me your kids really are
desperate to go back there no
so you hated school but then you know
that you could have gotten a job at the
plant or something right you chose to
roam around the country yeah I don't
know I I
it's not like my parents were they
weren't uh artistic at all but uh they
they were all for me going out next I
was going to be an actor when I was 18
and as soon as I was legal to run uh at
18 I went to Hollywood with 450 in my
pocket took the train across country and
went to
and I learned more in three months of
what Hollywood actually is I'm trying to
survive how would you summarize that
uh
it's the trial by fire
it's like boot camp for real life like
okay
oh these are gay prostitutes and they
work out of this I thought I was getting
a really good deal on this uh share of
bathroom uh uh hostile place oh these
are yeah oh now it's not a woman after
all okay
uh so yeah the nine years I completed of
schooling paled in comparison to three
months of living in Hollywood when did
you realize like was there a particular
moment you're like okay I don't want to
be an actor I want to be a stand-up
uh well comedy kicked off I moved to LA
in 85 and it was I had moved at this
point I was living in Las Vegas uh in
1990 and that was at the height of uh
stand up comedy the Boom the 80s boom
was just and you don't think that was
because of Ronald Reagan you think it
was independent of who was president no
okay uh yeah it was actually uh George
Bush because when I started Open Mic
they they started the uh they kicked off
that first war there yeah and I remember
sitting in a in a bar that I regulared
and having a pen and a notepad trying to
make funny out of the world do you
remember what your first I don't know
jokes uh specific to
the Gulf War but what was your favorite
so bad back then anyway
they didn't even have to have truth to
them what was your favorite
um uh 911 joke
or what is your favorite 911 joke
I had one I really loved and again my
bits are not succinct and Camera
friendly but it was it was a I think six
months after the war
I was about the death toll and how they
were they first said as over 10 000
people dead and then it went down and
it's eight thousand and six thousand and
um and now they're saying it's a 3 300
people died at this rate I believe oh
that was the premise when is it going to
be okay to make jokes again and I went
through the the death toll limit So my
answer is June 3rd because at this rate
no one will have died from 9 11. the
amount of decline if this yeah by then
zero people will have died
what uh you mentioned your jokes when
you were starting I didn't have truth to
them yeah what talk a little bit about
that because like a lot of stand-ups or
a lot of comedians talk about being
truth tellers
um
yeah but I was a 23 year old guy that
just I couldn't sing at karaoke or I
wasn't athletic so hey this is a way to
get noticed in a bar and uh maybe get
laid uh because I'm kind of funny sea
monkeys I remember uh sea monkeys is a
funny reference and I I remember writing
a bit backwards like sea monkeys started
it and okay how do I make it and it was
something about sexually transmitted sea
monkeys or something I don't know but so
yeah just but it didn't have truth no no
I don't know because they're not really
monkeys it's just funny words to say how
do I get people to laugh yeah so then
what are what is now I don't give a [__]
if they laugh now and now I go am I
amused
uh do does the audience win or lose in
that
I think normally they can tell if you're
enjoying yourself they're coming along
for the ride because they don't know
what's funny or they wouldn't have
[__] paid you to come in if they
could do this themselves what uh you
know your humor is uh typically
described and I think the sacred as dark
or yeah I mean like you you like
immediately to go into places where most
people don't uh and spaces I guess I
understand why you do that like you're
driven to do that
um why do you think people who are not
doing that on a regular basis what
what's the interest in you know in going
along for a ride with somebody who is
driving into very dark places
first of all if people really believe
these are the end of times then we're
all living in a dark place and you need
to to
find the funny in it I would love to see
cancel culture go after the people who
live in Dark Places First Responders
EMTs people are known for having the
most caustic because they have to Crime
Scene detective hardened you know
firefighter and they're making the most
repulsive jokes back at the station
about your grandmother's corpse that
they've just peeled out of a burning
building and yeah go ahead cancel them
yeah they made fun of your grandmother
just minutes after she died yeah that's
how you live I just we just had our last
podcast uh of neighbors and Friends uh
at uh one of their tweaker friends of
meth psychosis think oh everyone's
trying to harvest my organs I'm gonna
kill everyone in the house it was an
attempted mass murder down the street
and uh our friend usually the open mic
comedian she got her heel blown off uh
and uh you know oh this is going to be a
great podcast finally we have something
fun to talk about let's get
how did that go over it's uh we had a
blast yeah I don't know how it's the
podcast so it's not like a crowd where
you can tell if they laughed or not but
yeah most of our our most listened to
podcasts were a suicide of you know
a death something tragic and uh did they
uh did they I mean they found the guy
who was involved in that shooting and
whatnot right because you're it was a
lady a gal yeah yeah and um she just
snapped or yeah she would she's you know
do you work I was used to be pro-drug
but now I'm a little bit more selective
because meth heads are [__] just
do you think do you think is the country
getting more violent
or as a kind of aesthetic sells tickets
so you I I don't know I remember how one
of the books that really changed my
point of view was you were being lied to
disinfo.com is a compendium of different
essays about things you think you know
and the first black baseball player was
uh you know no no they actually had
black baseball players you know during
Reconstruction I mean but they don't
count that right uh and just all these
you know you're being lied to and one of
them was about mass shootings and how
like it gave numbers about yeah they
were mass shootings they just didn't get
as much coverage or school shootings now
I think that's probably not correct
because this was in the 90s I'm sure
there are more shootings but
I think people are more on edge thinking
that everyone else is violent because
that's what they sell on TV so
everyone's in a like a reactive like
someone's on my lawn yeah do you like
what do you think's going on then that
were you know that we're we're more
hyped I mean is it just TV and the way
people talk about stuff or is there
something changing in American culture I
I noticed this when I was just even as a
teenager uh you pick up the paper and I
I know that I'm reading about the murder
I'm reading about the the
the brawl at the thing and oh the tax
rates in this local school Union things
I skipped skip yeah so yeah if you if
you you eat a diet of all [__]
but is it like I mean you you may be a
little too young to remember like Jim
Jones no no okay yeah we're uh the
Zodiac Killer is a little bit before
your time but Son of Sam would have been
a thing and like you know you would read
just the weirdest things there was that
um
School Bus full of children in
California that were kidnapped and like
buried underground it was turned into
like part of the Dirty Harry I mean but
it was it seemed like in the 70s
certainly or then John Wayne Gacy would
you know come into view or something
there was something totally weird and
[__] up happening all the time
yeah and I mean so was that driving the
turn to talk about violence and serial
killers and stuff like that or was it do
they get conjured by the way that we
talk about stuff
I know down now you're getting into the
murder porn area why why and that's
mostly a female thing it seems to be uh
why now we're watching well you say I'm
too young to know about these things but
I wouldn't be because they're all
popular now right every every mass
murderer from yeah
almost dominating like Netflix for a
month or something like that
yeah and if people don't watch Happy
[__] yeah uh what do what do you watch
I don't I I watch almost no comedy like
comedy if it's a comedy on television
that's a buzzword for not funny I
couldn't tell you a single actual sitcom
that's on a network right now the only
time I ever see commercials uh is
watching football
that's the only thing I watch in real
time everything else I can't yeah this
dvr'd or Netflix so it's either no
commercials or I can fast forward
through them
uh so yeah I don't watch anything funny
because I can't find it uh
so yeah I watch whatever's uh you know
bingeable yeah uh you I guess I'm uh
you were on Louis CK's show uh this is
years ago on FX
on and you played was it yourself or a
version of it was certainly a version it
was he had it as an amalgamation of a
lot of comedians that he thought I would
do well at not knowing that no he's I'm
playing exactly myself right it was it
was me if I hadn't made any money in
comedy but still doing it for you know
beer money and uh you've have a bit
that's very funny and you're I highly
recommend your Instagram feed is just
great because it's just clips from all
over your career that are short and very
funny but you uh in one of them you talk
about how Louis got contact by Robin
Williams and said like your performance
was like a searing you know just a great
bit about suicide Etc like shortly
before he died and what is your bit
that's related now I think maybe I could
as much as he was a great influence on
other Comics maybe I was a great
influence on the last days of Robin
Williams life and his his decisions yeah
uh that was the bit as far as I know
yeah and I mean do you uh like audiences
seem to love that do you have to give
them permission to laugh at that kind of
humor I don't know I I'm not a comedian
that uh steps out of my comfort zone I'm
not a guy that goes to the comedy seller
and works out you know a new bit or I I
perform to my paid audience only like
this will be interesting and freedom
Fest because there will be people that
are not here to see Doug Stanhope
they're they're here to see comedy and
it'll be fun but I will cherry pick the
bits that are Freedom Fest related or
maybe mocking of uh but still it'll be
I'm not gonna try to drag them into some
other part of my reality that's not
that's foreign soil but it's still I
don't I don't work stuff out if I have
new [__] I'm gonna do it tonight at my
show that in front of my fans yeah and I
think I worked under 33 years now yeah
at some point yeah I'm gonna completely
lay back on my Laurels right I mean you
you could be bad like I I had school
teachers who were you know at it for 30
years who sucked yeah so like but but
the audience tells you already right
yeah hey if they're going to pay 55 60
to get in uh they're not yeah what um
what went into I you know one of the
things that I think is is genuinely
fascinating about your career and and I
realize like you're not for all tastes
right but you have a great career and
you've also really refused to I as
sellout isn't the right word because
there's people who have made it
gigantically big who are doing exactly
what they want to and they force
networks and audiences to come to them
rather than yeah any of that but what
goes into the calculation of you know of
being like a really independent voice in
a form where there is a mass audience
like you know how do you do that um and
how do you keep at that I I guess what
I'm saying is there's there's a couple
you know there's a there are not that
many comedians who have the opportunity
to go super big Who Remain true to what
they are like you you know you haven't
got you haven't done a sitcom where you
are you know the bachelor dad who
inherits a family of alligators I
haven't turned a lot of stuff down
I mean maybe I'm wrong I there's there's
well there's things that I I wouldn't do
but I I have never had to been in a
place where I go oh dude the man show
was the thing where I went okay yeah for
that kind of money uh but I had no idea
was gonna suck like I didn't know no
going in that
oh they they you you can do whatever you
want with it and your own voice so they
were saying that yeah and then when it
came with it oh you know filming day
wait we I thought yeah the lawyer said
no on this and the sensor said no on
that so we're gonna go with the other
thing that the writers wrote and that
sucks
how did that feel if that's why I left
La that's why do you live in Bisbee
because I did the one thing you're
supposed to want to do in LA the only
reason you live there is to get a thing
and I go it sucked and uh
the only I'm the only guy who did a TV
show that became less popular because
like I had my comedy career going fine
you know
people think I suck so so yeah I don't
need to be in La I'd rather live in a
small town so
I I wanted to ask in the uh in your book
uh this is not fame from a couple years
ago which is a great Memoir and you
you're you're over your bookshelf is is
building up it's pretty good one I hope
you keep writing them uh but you had Dr
Drew Pinsky uh wrote a forward uh to
um to this is not fame and you said uh
he wrote one day Doug may need or have
to change do you have you had to change
it uh I had well I did I did quit
smoking I'm a of February so this is
July
I did it was not nearly as hard as I
I've been trying I did blood work for
the first time as an adult I went and
actually got a physical because I
thought it'd be funny because it and I
thought oh there's gonna be some you
know my lifestyle there's some [__] now
I'm in really good health my liver is
great what kidneys find blood sugar no
diabetes and the only thing uh high
cholesterol not too bad but
triglycerides through the roof and uh so
I've been trying to change all these
diet things trying to added sugar just
way harder than quitting smoking just
cutting sugar out I would yeah what
about drinking drinking I've I've yeah
that's where I'm uh I'm toying with it
yeah I've been trying to drink a wine
drink less obviously and uh okay wine uh
supposedly better they won't tell you a
lot of [__] like when you look up and
Google okay what alcohol is best for
high triglycerides they're not going to
say
and I'm sure someone knows but you
they're just going to say yeah you
shouldn't drink alcohol at all alcohol
is bad for you anyway
yeah you know there's there's someone
who knows
what uh what about other drugs how are
you uh what what drugs that's still
that's what I'm really my my weak spot
is I haven't been doing any
hallucinogens and I need to yeah what's
the benefit of hallucinogens I just it
clears out all your [__] uh you know
if you Slough off all that you know the
things that you're doing wrong and the
the fears that are irrational that
you're so I always think of it as like
clearing your web browser cache right
yeah yeah it's a why aren't you brain
douche just because you get to the older
you get the more [__] the more baggage
that you're gonna have to deal with and
you go
it has dirty dishes and you you look at
it and you go I don't want to deal with
that but the longer you don't deal with
it the higher the stat gets and then you
don't want to deal with it more so I do
want to do an Ayahuasca binge I do have
a a bit about that on the new special
but uh I just don't want to deal with a
like a shaman that ruins it yeah do you
worry about uh like psychedelics are
really hot right now yeah does that fill
you with hope or does it fill you with
things no I think that I think it's a
fantastic thing uh but that's why the
the whole the
medical the trip or tourism that they're
doing and how they and they use uh this
the bit is in part that they use uh uh
hallucinogens for PTSD all these reasons
uh end of life situation struggles and
uh getting over depression they use it
for everything except fun right which is
what got me into I want to do it but
have fun the whole Shaman route they
don't want you to have fun I want to do
my own version of it and uh
have a sober sitter but not a guy with
face paint chanting right
um you uh wrote in uh no Aqua for the
donkey which is your most recent book
right
um the more you experience an age the
more you can count on diminishing
returns what yeah do you remember
writing that or no I I I I tell do you
believe that
yeah I I I I I think I could stand by
that what what's the context uh you know
it's
got it was was it towards the beginning
or the end of that book but it was it
was part of a passage of yeah I I it's
kind of a takes one to know one thing
where sometimes I'll be watching TV and
hear some dialogue and you go I know the
writer whoever wrote that was probably a
high five in himself when he wrote that
clever [__] line because I'm probably
the guy that was high-fiving myself so I
wrote a guy like that sounds well do you
I mean you know do you feel like uh
there's there's new stuff that you're
going to be experiencing or are you kind
of like have you hit the point where now
your life is just kind of a steady state
it might be mine but that's exactly why
I need to do hallucinogens because I do
need to I know there's there's new
different things to do but I'm also
really good at pre-judging what I'm
gonna hate yeah like I I know I know I'm
gonna uh I knew I was gonna hate the UK
going over there and every every
preconceived notion was right and I
hated it
yeah but you've done well there
yeah and I have to go back and hate it
because it pays well well now that their
money's worth [__] nothing yeah okay
uh
but uh yeah I I
went uh
you know skydiving you know
I remember Bingo and I we went uh it's
not skydiving what's on the boat
parasailing parasailing and we're
hungover we had partied all night in
Tampa the night before and I remember
it's just there were three of us we're
just sitting there we couldn't have been
more bored if it was an elevator it's
like this is nothing so what if what
excites you though is is there anything
chaos yeah yeah when the [__]
neighbor just got their foot blown off
in an attempted mass murder you go okay
that's yeah that kind of stuff is where
I thrive I'm like all right rally the
troops yeah we we got fun going on do
you expect that to increase uh in the
coming years and if so why
I have no idea I don't know what's going
on with people anymore I I used to
there was some kind of comfort in having
a false sense of knowing what's going on
in the world and having an opinion like
I used to uh and now I know that I'm
probably wrong about a lot of [__] and
so but let me stay away until I have a
better footing does that fit into
libertarian thinking at all like I mean
is that part of your libertariness of
like you don't you know that you don't
really know that much
the the problem with uh knowing that you
don't know that much and admitting it
people don't people want uh uh you know
false bravado they want uh even if it's
got no backing they want someone who and
this is what it is and I'll tell you and
I I know and do you I mean do you you
don't think like people are finally
getting fed up with that like after
covid and whatnot because that's what we
had right oh my God the same people
would say you know you got to do this
this week and then next week with
exactly the same level of authority and
determination and commitment now you got
to do this and I I thought people would
get to a place where and and even that
that part of my act that I was doing
after you know quarantine was over and I
was back on the road about it's okay to
not have an opinion it's okay to not
know did not get the reaction uh that I
that I was hoping for yeah so it's like
it opens up for a little bit and then
people are like God now we've got to go
back everyone's a conspiracy theorist
now I loved conspiracy theories as a
form of entertainment from again 911 to
uh to Oklahoma City Bombing all of them
and uh
and but for fun yeah yeah and not as a
personality and now everyone has got
some conspiracy and they're all and
they're bad they're so bad they're
conspiracy theories why do you think
there's a lot of conspiracy theories uh
theorists and Libertarians like what do
you is there a connect do you see a
connection between those two I do I've
I've don't know why I was so intrigued
with I mean even UFOs
yeah this is kind of like aren't we
supposedly like there's people now of
like I've seen the bodies
allegedly yeah but then it never happens
there's there's so many uh Avenues of
information that you don't know who's
reading what about what and I well I
read a thing but there's 80 things now
there's not one like loose change I I oh
I saw loose change and this is how I
feel but there's only a couple of uh
sources that everyone's what do you
think is the pleasure of a conspiracy
theory as you know from like an artistic
point of view what did you enjoy I think
it's just like any other be a sleuth a
lot of people play Clue I don't know uh
yeah and then I touch on that in the
special but it's there's there's
something about it that almost reeks of
being a [__] narc right hey you know
what it's none of your business if
aliens came to this planet they didn't
come to meet you so [__] leave it
alone you're the one who wanted a
government so uh let them [__] handle
it why did you become libertarian is
that like were you born with it or was
it life someone told me I was oh really
yes someone's libertarian so when I was
doing stuff that uh you do realize like
everybody's score is libertarian on the
world's smallest political quiz like it
took me a while to realize that it
wasn't me it was like yeah it's that
that that thing yeah
um so somebody told you you were yeah
the based on you see my ACT they go
you're very libertarian you're
libertarian because yeah the things you
say and I go oh okay and so I looked
into libertarianism and yeah yeah I
scored that uh what among your uh
influences are Bill Hicks right or is
that fair to say or Bill Hicks I didn't
get into till till later on in comedy
when I was already again when you get
compared to him you go okay yeah but I I
knew of them but I was because I was I
was gonna say like what do you think of
like a lot of Comedians and I think
Hicks is a good example Mitch Hedberg
also who you get compared to
they aren't libertarian like they I mean
in a way they're anti-authority which is
nice but they're kind of like the worst
sort of anti-corporate you know like
yeah no that advertisers have you know
that's why I'm sucking on these cancer
sticks you know because of advertising
yeah I think that's the well the drug
angle of you know free drugs and the
socially
yeah that that's where they say oh Bill
Hicks is libertarian but no I think he
would definitely be [__] taxing this
[__] out of Corporations or Bernie
Sanders yeah you'd definitely be more
Bernie Sanders than Gary Johnson do you
even have a [__] candidate last
election who's who's way the
Libertarians oh yeah yeah it was Joe
Jorgensen
a uh psychology lecture from uh uh
Clemson all right yeah my wife and I we
uh my tour manager co-host producer
best friends they live next to us and
when the when the ballots cup would just
drop it off in their mailbox you drop
our drop our ballots off you vote for us
good that's as good a you know processes
just about anybody else's
um who are you who who do you think are
the best comedians
and why
uh like today in general names yeah
let's uh start with today yeah name some
names well I I like the the you just put
Hedberg and Bill Hicks in the same yeah
uh sentence because when people do say
or you're talking about oh comedy's
about truth and comedy's about you know
being a real and uh saying what
everybody thinks and is afraid to say no
Hedberg talking about uh ducks eat free
at Subway wasn't right well actually
that story is based a true story but he
was silly he was [__] fun and silly
and it didn't have to be any truth to it
it was Ridiculousness and um he's the
one I think he the one who started the
joke of like why would people who are
high on LSD go to roofs of buildings to
see if they could fly like why wouldn't
they just take off from the street
yeah I remember him talking about uh
doing acid uh in the in the in the woods
so they wouldn't run into authority
figures but we ran into a bear it was
way worse
so you like that kind of stuff yeah I
loved Hedberg and he's always a great
person that to use as an example when
Comics start talking about how [__]
lofty and it's our position to fight for
free speech and we have to and we're in
the Vanguard you know
Society right yeah there's there's
comedians have gotten so self-important
I have a a there's a one this girl uh I
do remember her name I'm just not going
to say it but just a tweet where you
know when Twitter became unfun and she
wrote I will never meet a racist halfway
based on whatever racism that is I'm
like that's a completely wrong attitude
yeah we're all fighting for the minds of
the stupid here and if someone's
outwardly racist that means they're
probably really lonely and they're
joining a group that's going to let them
in yeah [__] me to race is halfway
and bring them over to your side of the
street and then you get and and get a
fan and then you just mold his stupid
little head with what you want him to
think because uh yeah otherwise you're
leaving money on the table dummy
uh who uh who are some people today that
you find really uh good uh
God is uh you know I I have an answer
for you by the end of the summer because
I am taking at least a year off okay
I'll start watching them because I uh
during quarantine like uh guys like Sam
Morrell new guys that I just uh because
I don't want to watch Comedy I don't
want to ever I'm you know I drink enough
I don't want to ever be in a position of
this is a great bit I just thought of or
did I see it from that guy's special
maybe I should ask him oh [__] what's
that guy's name I watched his special I
can't remember what about from the past
like who were who who's on your Mount
Rushmore of Comedy uh there's that still
hold up uh but guys like Steven Wright I
loved and they and Hedberg you can still
watch there there their [__] still holds
up uh sometimes you watch Comics it's
sad when you watch a Bill Hicks and a
bit of his is still like that was a
problem you know 35 years ago and it's
still a problem that shouldn't be like I
want that to be to a hackneyed it's it's
sad when even Lenny Bruce talking about
yeah yeah oh yes why can't we do this I
can't feed the poor whatever right yeah
too bad that's still a problem what uh
you know what what do you hope
for I I was about to say for the future
like obviously not for your kids because
you don't have kids do you hate kids
yeah I really yeah I have a real problem
um so what I mean you are uh I looked it
up you're born in 1967 I can't do the
math so you're 50 56 56 uh you know
you're gonna live especially now that
you're drinking wine and you're you know
you cut out smoke you're gonna live for
like another 30 years yeah how are you
gonna handle that like what do you do
today it's uh yeah that's new it's only
a couple months that I realized oh I
might not die like I expected that like
I was trying to live as long as mother
who made it to 63 with their yeah the
emphysema and all that uh
and now I yeah I don't know
well you're gonna blow by that right
well yeah that early retirement I was
thinking about I think I'm probably
gonna have to start writing some more
[__] jokes
yeah how do how do you like what what
gets you not what gets you up in the
morning how do you go through the day
especially if you're peeling back you're
you're getting rid of the things that
you use to get through the days you're
not smoking you're not doing
psychedelics as much
um you're shifting to to healthy you
know fruit-based alcoholic beverages I
you would have
no idea how much joy I get out of just
doing dumb [__] like just making new
recipes now that I had to change my diet
and okay okay for cholesterol I can do
like red beans and rice never did that
before and I'll spend I'd love to cook I
love to go thrift store shopping and
find a bargain that tuxedo I was wearing
last night a dollar Nick a [__]
dollar I'm a natural order it was in my
mother's jeans but uh so yeah I like the
hoard a quarantine I I get all my suits
like by color and Order and like how
many suits do you have I think this was
before I have the house fire so I had
like I paired it down like 35 jackets
yeah and uh but then I've been buying
I've been buying for a year yeah what's
the most that you've ever spent on a
jacket oh uh one time there was one Lily
Pulitzer uh green floral thing that I
think I spent 600 bucks on that's
incredible generally you could get a car
for that yeah I I I I I spent a lot of
money 600 cars yeah I don't want to go
back yet uh generally speaking what do
you pay like five bucks ten bucks for a
jacket yeah do you get them tailored
then uh if I yeah if if it's good enough
I'll get it yeah it's great when you buy
it find a three dollar jacket and a
thrift store but then I'd cost you like
25 to get it tailored when did that
start
I started that that started early on in
my telemarketing days because my mother
would send me like goofy suits we you
know from thrift stores back when you
know vintage was
yeah yeah it wasn't this pre-vantage
this was just like late late 80s so this
is just
you know [__] that it just went out of
style 10 years ago so it's really cheap
and she'd send me these so we'd all
dress up in the telemarketing office and
used car salesman suits and then uh then
uh throughout my career I've worn dumb
[__] like for a while I would wear a
Santa hat year round for no reason and
then
uh with the telemarketing stuff you've
been kind of critical of yourself or at
least of the stuff you were selling
right like you've described some of the
the telemarketing stuff you did it you
know as as essentially scams right yeah
does that throw into any question for
you like the the the use of like free
markets and things like that because I
could see a comedian who does that and
then it's like this is why I hate
capitalism and freedom
um but you're not that comedian no I
mean I I I hate that I
I had absolutely no moral compass about
all right I'm ripping people off because
and you were definitely ripping up you
were definitely ripping them off for it
was a gray area so you say hey you're
gonna win a big prize if you've ordered
this product and you know the prize
isn't going to be that big and but you
didn't say how big it was you it
insinuated it's gonna be bigger than
what they're spending but it's not so
they're not going to be happy uh the
hopefully they're not so angry that they
try to come after and find out who you
are and prosecute uh so yeah I should
have had it but it was early 20s I
didn't give a [__] I was making a lot of
money do you I mean do you think it's up
to people like caveat mtor let the buyer
beware or
my problem
with libertarianism the more I got
involved and realized how much I don't
know I can't call myself a Libertarian
like that [__] that Pharma bro guy
yeah would libertarianism say hey it's
his rights of jack up [__] this AIDS
medication through the roof and [__]
them if they die because I think that's
a Libertarian attitude and I I'd go I
can't yeah I mean yeah on some level yes
but then it's also like the Pharma
Market is so regulated Etc like
Libertarians could weasel their way out
of any bad Market outcome right because
they'll say well you know the FDA you
know runs all of that kind of stuff and
so the government's thumb prints are on
everything because otherwise people
would come out with generic versions of
every drug and you know they'd be free
or close to free and that's why it's
guys like that maybe is the answer to
the question of why we're all into this
fantasy murder stuff yeah because you
can't really murder people so let's just
watch other people who did murder people
and yeah Elevate their status yeah I
want to watch more Dahmer yeah because I
can't punch Pharma bro in the face
okay
um when is your special gonna come out
uh especially without a name a special
will come out as soon as I get it edited
and where will we find it I don't know
that's then my manager will try to shop
it around I think I might just put it up
here's a I wanted to do this with the
last special it came out right at the
beginning of quarantine uh but it had
been filmed long before
uh you porn
uh agreed to release my new special and
I thought that's really funny gimmick
but that was also right around the time
that they were getting busted for like
having like revenge porn rape porn
people say that I couldn't certify that
you were out of 18.
because you don't have a driver's
license because you're a Libertarian
right uh do you worry at all I was
talking with other people in different
contexts here at Freedom Fest some
people who had uh put out you know
they've created movies and documentaries
that are pretty you know controversial
and they were saying like you know what
I I don't want to you know I don't want
to go to Netflix I don't want to go to
Amazon video I don't even want to go to
YouTube because you put stuff up and you
really don't have any you know guarantee
that they're not in a couple days
they're going to be like you know what
we did we're blocking this and we own
the rights and things like that do you
worry about that at all because your
comedy is yeah I hate like the word edgy
it just isn't right for it but like you
put out the type of stuff that you could
see people getting really pissed at and
saying like we got to shut this and a
lot of it's out there that's yeah I'm at
a place where I'm not famous enough to
know if I've been canceled like I had
stuff on Netflix that it's not there
anymore but this everything that goes on
Netflix eventually goes away nothing's
permanent and they don't tell you you
don't have a con they don't go hey by
the way you're pulling we're pulling
your [__] down you don't know so if you
got canceled a lot of the stuff that did
air on Netflix they would pull down for
Content reasons there's stuff that you
go oh yeah yeah definitely couldn't get
away with that now do you think I mean
are we too uh touchy or sensitive as a
society like is that something you go
back to the 70s and this might be a good
way to to wrap things up with beautiful
symmetry since we started talking about
the 70s you know when you look at stuff
that was on like you know CBS NBC and
ABC in the 70s where you know on like
all in the family or something they
would use racial and ethnic epithets
like as filler words words but if you
said [__] my God the [__] roof's
falling off so it's a trade out you
could say [__] back then but you
couldn't the [__] is going to get you
right canceled you couldn't even have
beer right like I mean for a while on TV
it wouldn't you couldn't have a brand of
beer it would just say beer yeah I think
I actually I still in play uh in ads for
a liquor that liquor ads came back but
they can't show them actually drinking
it but again they trade out one you
can't do this but now you can do this
but you can't do the other thing so the
censorship is like always in motion but
do you think overall like if you tallied
it all up and stuff like that would you
say it's you know where it's Freer now
like you can do and say more things and
more places than say in 1980 or
something yeah it's a million Outlets
yeah if you want it just be really
offensive
they can't stop you because they're it's
there's too much whack-a-mole okay and
there's a new streaming service opening
up here I will let you say anything and
then they get shut down and then so it's
yeah and that's good exactly there's a
loophole you'll exploit it they shut it
down you open up a new loophole that
just keeps going like that so that's
kind of beautiful yeah I know that's why
the government has always been just
another thing okay I'm a rat and a maze
and there's a bunch of things out there
who do you worry about more like do you
worry about the government or the
corporations or the the churches or are
they all kind of equal to you in terms
of they're all trying to to trap well I
think
lawyers uh
are the ones who you worry about getting
sued or audited those I don't know if
that comes with age but yeah
those the ones that scare me the most
uh final uh I used to work as a uh music
journalist and a teen magazine editor
and we would always
say you know if you were talking to Kirk
Cameron in 1986 or 87 or Ozzy Osbourne
or whatever the final question was
always message to your fans Doug
Stanhope message to your fans
uh yeah don't don't kill yourself it's
not worth it
I don't I don't have a message for my
fans if I do I will wrap it in a fist
[__] joke and call it new material so
you'll get the message at the show
I appreciate that very much that's a
great message thank you thank you
[Music]